huit jardins et 2 arboretum dans ce parc
paysager de 14 hectares de l'asie à
l'amérique
sept mille arbres et arbustes de
nombreuses espèces rares mais l'espèce
la plus rare est le visiteur en cette
période de confinement car ce parc se
situe à plus dé dix kilomètres d'orléans
le problème c'est que pour le moment on
ne sait pas si les gens ont le droit de
venir nous voir à maximum 10 km ou un
maximum 30 km et donc ce qu'on espère
c'est être reconnu comme mieux culturel
et du coup ils puissent faire veut faire
30 km pour venir nous voir cet arboretum
est un lieu unique
il reste à être classé en lieu culturel
par le préfet du loiret c'est compliqué
oui surtout que c'est assez isolé comme
endroit donc il faut vraiment habitait
tout près pour pouvoir venir
sinon c'est trop loin mais c'est
vraiment un endroit incroyable quoi vous
attendez quelque chose l'entamé les
oiseaux c'est tout et ça c'est paisible
et c'est tranquille et donc ces quelques
personnes en besoin d'avoir justement
c'est ce calme et cette tranquillité
dans un endroit harmonieux faut que ce
soit harmonieux c'est très important
des sons des couleurs et des arbres mais
surtout des passionnés qui vous donne
envie de respirer autrement on a envie
de montrer tout ça à tout le monde et
donc aujourd'hui on sait que l'arboretum
et très beau qui a beaucoup de choses en
fleurs qui a beaucoup de choses à voir
le printemps est là est vraiment là et
on aimerait que les visiteurs soient là
aussi pour pour le voir aucun doute ce
lieu sera un lieu culturel où il fera
bon allez dans le monde d'après